der gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
ist ganz interessant er hat heute nicht
auf der regierungsbank platz genommen
sondern er hat sich auf seinen
abgeordneten platz gesetzt das heißt der
wiener kenntlich machen das ist eine
sache der parlamentarier heute er kann
natürlich nicht aus seiner haut
gesundheitsminister bleibt
gesundheitsminister aber der bilder
heute als einfacher abgeordneter
mitdiskutieren der justizminister wird
nach vorne gehen auch gleich schon marco
buschmann von der fdp gregor gysi wird
vorne stehen alles weidl für die afg und
und und allerhand prominente namen claus
strunz bei uns bild live im studio
findest du jeder muss sich jetzt auch
bekennen in dieser frage die deutschland
seit wochen diskutiert in der man über
die man in der familie diskutiert im
freundeskreis hier bei uns bei der
arbeit ganz heftig wir wissen von
unseren kollegen wer steht wofür findest
du das zumindest auf der regierungsbank
bei jedem klar sein müsste pro oder
contra impfpflicht in der absolut und
ich glaube dass die entscheidende frage
heute sein wird und wenn schon so viel
großkopferte sprechen auch wirklich groß
ist in ihrem kopf drin ist dass man
wirklich sozusagen auch die debatte
nicht nur in einer ewig selben
argumentationsmuster maschinerie die man
nicht mehr hören kann von diesen
politikern die nie was neues zu stande
bringen ist sondern das wirklich ein
neuer ich würde fast sagen augen öffnen
da aspekt mit minister danach sehne ich
mich auch und wenn diese augen öffnen
aspekt gegen meine bisherige these ist
dann wert schätze ich den und beziehen
meine überlegung ein und das hoffe ich
eben wechselseitig und was lauterbach
angeht und den gang auf seinen
abgeordnetensitz das finde ich schon
schuppen voller großer symbolkraft man
könnte beim ersten nachdenken denen es
ist feige also er will sozusagen mit der
verantwortung als gesundheitsminister
nichts zu tun haben ich will aber nur
mehr daran erinnern olaf scholz hat
hierbei bild das was wir heute erleben
angeregt in dem er gesagt hat er wünscht
sich eine entscheidung des parlaments
bei freien mandat also das bedeutet
niemand ist an den oftmals zu setzenden
fraktionszwang gebunden also ich bin
eigentlich der meinung ich sehe es
anders habe es auch in meinem wahlkreis
versprochen aber jetzt hat dann der
großkopferte fraktionsvorsitzende
entschieden wir gehen da lang und dann
muss ich leider bei der
muss ich mich irgendwie einen bolzen ja
das alles ist ja aufgehoben das ist
aufgehoben jeder kann nur nach seinem
gewissen entscheiden und das wird sehr
sehr spannend zu beobachten sein wem
fühlen sich die abgeordneten eigentlich
wirklich verantwortlich ihrem gewissen
ihre wähler oder
das ist eine sehr große frage die geht
auch mit wenn man in dieses parlament
heute rein guckt sitzt die damit drin
und ich hoffe wirklich dass ist eine
eine unkonditionierte der
mehrheitsmeinung geben wird von für die
impfpflicht
gegen die allgemeine impfpflicht und
wenn es nur ist dass man die gedanken
verbindet also dass man sagt ich stelle
einen antrag wir probieren jetzt noch
mal wirklich alles alles alles alles
nicht mit so einer toiletten kampagne
wie schuld sie hoch gehalten hat sondern
mit einer wirklichen kampagne mit einem
wirklich bilateralen gespräch mensch für
menschen mit argumenten mit geschichten
die man erzählen kann mit
überzeugungskraft mit passion mit
ehrlichkeit könnten uns auch mal
versuchen ist natürlich gibt es
nebenwirkungen das wieder so ein
klassiker jeder weiß doch dass es neben
wäre jedes verdammte medikament jede
schmerztablette keine ahnung was alles
nicht sooo einwerfen haben
nebenwirkungen aber nein der impfstoff
hat bestimmt keine nebenwirkung das ist
ein unsinniges unglaubwürdiges
argumentationsmuster müssen ja es sind
nebenwirkungen aber die sind weniger
gefährlich als das andere das alles wenn
wir durch probiert haben dann können wir
gerne im nächsten oktober uns nochmal
über eine impfpflicht unterhalten ich
glaube wenn das mit großer verve und
überzeugung gemacht würde dann bräuchte
die impfpflicht gar nicht und diese
schwierige debatte die aber am ende
wichtig ist weil sie viel über unser
demokratieverständnis starken wird
orientierungs debatte so der offizielle
titel des ganzen claus strunz unserer
bild live chef vielen herzlichen dank
für sein leidenschaftliches engagement
hier auch die debatte hier leicht ins
studio zu bringen es werden im laufe
dieser sendung werden für die debatte
auch im bundestag weiter verfolgen immer
wieder machen auch hier diskutieren wir
erklären einmal die bilder die sie neben
und zehn wir schauen live in den
bundestag impfpflicht ja oder nein dort
läuft die debatte wir schauen ganz genau
mit einer extra kamera noch mal auf den
sitz des gesundheitsministeriums
lauterbach ihm stets in die augen
schauen und wir schauen natürlich auch
was passiert hier auf den straßen in der
hauptstadt viele menschen versammeln
sich jetzt bereits um gegen die
impfpflicht zudem genau die polizei
spricht so von jahr zwei 3000 menschen
aktuell dort rund um den reichstag unter
den linden wo wir hier gerade auch mit
unserer kamera sind mit dieser demo käme
also so sieht es draußen aus während
drinnen im bundestag jetzt sich die
debatte langsam hitziger entwickelt wir
gehen gleich dorthin haben aber noch
peter tiede bei uns im programm der hat
gerade schon mit dem justizminister mit
marco buschmann gesprochen was denkt
marco buschmann unser neuer
fdp-justizminister über die impfpflicht
ja oder nein
impfpflicht ja nein und die frage gehen
wir mal direkt weiter an den
bundesjustizminister herr buschmann von
der fdp herr buschmann impfpflicht ja
nein die frage ist komplizierter es gibt
ja nicht nur ja nein es gibt
beispielsweise eine gestufte im pflicht
des bundes gilt zu prüfen ob es mildere
mittel zu einer impfpflicht gibt weil
sie im ziel sind wir alle einig wir
wollen wirklich schnell raus aus den
kontakt beschränkungen und aus diesen
ganzen dingen wir wollen möglichst ein
herbst ohne überlastete intensivstation
erleben und darum muss es heute gehen
also ist der ministerrat schon
entschieden oder noch unentschieden der
minister in amtlicher funktion hält sich
zurück weil wir uns bewusst entschieden
haben dass das parlament hier in der
ersten reihe steht aber der abgeordnete
buschmann wird heute an der debatte auf
teilnehmen und wird natürlich auch seine
meinung bilden wie viele andere
kolleginnen und kollegen auch im lichte
der argumente jetzt gibt es sehr große
zweifel daran dass man eine impfpflicht
machen kann wenn man gar nicht weiß
welche wie oft müssen sich die leute
impfen lass also was schreibt man da
rein kann man denn überhaupt jetzt schon
sagen wie oft sich die leute impfen
lassen müssten geht das dann auch wenn
der impfstoff noch nicht angepasst ist
oder ist das nicht sicher greifen viel
zu kompliziert als ich kann natürlich
jetzt erstmal berichten was die kollegen
die meinen das geht aufgeschrieben haben
also soweit ich informiert bin wollen
die befürworter eine allgemeine
impfpflicht also ab 18 es bei drei
impfungen belassen als verpflichtung
aber das ist natürlich eine frage die
man auch diskutieren kann ich will noch
mal sagen ich berichte jetzt hier nur
sondern und will das auch gar nicht vor
prägen weil wir wollen dass das
parlament im piloten sessel dieser
debatte sitzt weil diese frage so
wichtig die betrifft so viele millionen
menschen und wir spüren dass ihr alle im
freundeskreis im bekanntenkreis überall
details darüber diskutiert und deshalb
gehört sie ins parlament wenn man eine
nachfrage drei impfungen drei impfungen
pro jahr oder reichen dann meine drei
impfungen oder einmal gelesen zweimal
geimpft reicht das dann jetzt ewig also
eigentlich müssen sie die antragsteller
von habe ich habe es jedenfalls so
verstanden dass die die drei impfungen
meinen die heute zum status eines
geposteten führen also impfung 123 in
diesem jahr aber wenn sie das im laufe
der debatte noch dreht oder wenn die ihr
konzept nach der heutigen debatte
anpassen weil wir heute noch gar nicht
über texte entscheiden sondern wenn sie
so wollen so eine orientierungs debatte
durchführen wo erst mal alle erwägungen
auf den tisch kommen und man dann danach
möglicherweise nochmal die textarbeit
geht kann ich das natürlich gar nicht
abschließend beantworten weil ich bin ja
nicht initiator eine allgemeine
impfpflicht oder so sage ich nehme heute
als abgeordneter an dieser debatte teil
mit meiner meinung noch eine letzte ganz
einfache frage jeweils viel den
fragesteller kann es sein dass wir jetzt
ganz heftig ganz deutschland diskutiert
eine impfpflicht die wir vielleicht gar
nicht mehr brauchen also niemand kann
ausschließen dass sich das virus
verändert niemand kann sagen ob es im
herbst vielleicht milder oder vielleicht
wieder gefährlicher wird niemand kann
sagen ob es eine ganz neue virusvariante
geben kann wo man noch mal ganz neu
nachdenken kann das macht eben diese
entscheidung so schwierig das hat ja
auch das bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt
die entscheidungen der korona bekämpfung
die sie mit so viel unsicherheit mit
soviel prognose entscheidungen zur
abwägung verbunden dass da den
gesetzgeber eine ganz besondere
verantwortung trifft er hat zwar großen
spielraum aber umso größer ist auch die
verantwortung die inter trifft und
deshalb haben wir uns ja eben für dieses
sehr aufwendiger aber ich glaube
angemessene verfahren der gruppen
anträge entschieden dann bedanke ich
mich bei den zwei buschmann von denen
ich gerade gesprochen haben einmal die
minister und einmal den abgeordneten
vielen dank und damit zurück zu euch ins
studio
bitte die zwei burschen einfach eine
geschichte dieses tages ist auch der
gespaltene lauterbach heute als
bundestagsabgeordneter und als
gesundheitsminister das sind die bilder
die sie jetzt gerade auch live neben uns
sehen wir verfolgen live die debatte im
bundestag es geht um die impfpflicht ja
oder nein wir wollen aber natürlich auch
sehen was passiert hier auf den straßen
in der hauptstadt mehrere tausend
menschen haben sich dort versammelt um
gegen die impfpflicht zu demonstrieren
und wir wollen die debatte impfpflicht
ja oder nein auch hier live in dieser
sendung führen